لن يحسم الصراع في السودان الهيمنه
السياسيه والعسكريه في اقطار البلاد فقط
بل سيكتب مصير استثمارات تقدر بمليارات
الدولارات
ذهبوا احد مفاتيح السودان الكبير واهمها
في تغذيه النزاع الدائري منذ شهر ونصف ليس
جديدا لكنه يتجدد
[موسيقى]
منذ اواخر القرن التاسع عشر بدات الدول
الاستعماريه الكبرى بالبحث عن مصادر
لتمويل حروبها كان السودان لا يزال ارضا
بكرا منجما للعتاد البشري والذهب الاصفر
نعمه تحولت الى نقمه الاطماع الخارجيه
والداخليه لم تتوقف حتى بعد الاستقلال بل
استشرت العام الماضي صدر السودان فقط نحو
ثلث ما ينتجه من الذهب ثلاثون طنا فقط من
اصل 100 طن
ذهبت عوائدها الى خزينه الدوله والباقي تم
تهريبه الى الخارج
وبعائدته يمول الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع عددهم العسكريه والبشري
لتشفيف منابع التمويل فرضت واشنطن مؤخرا
عقوبات على شركات اتهمت باذكاء الصراع
السوداني منها شركتان مرتبطتان بالجيش
واخريان تتبعان لقوات الدعم السريع
احداهما تختص في تعدين الذهب اذ يدير قائد
الدعم السريع جزءا كبيرا من مناجم الذهب
كما ان للجيش شركات تدعم التنقيب بحسب
تقرير امريكي في السودان تتوزع مناجم
الذهب في صحاره وجبال شرق نهر النيل وفي
محاذاه البحر الاحمر واعلى سلسله جبال
البحر الاحمر ومناطق جبال النوبه واقليمي
كردفان ودارفور لكن اتساع رقعه الحرب
واستمرارها سيكبد البلد خسائر كبيره تزيد
من متوسط معدلات التضخم التي بلغت نسبتها
700 بالمئه وسيفقده مليارين ونصف المليار
دولار من عائداته المفارقه ان حق تصدير
الذهب لا يمنح الا شركات اجنبيه تجاوز
عددها ال 400 تستحوذ على نحو ثلاثمائه
كيلومتر مربع من اماكن الامتياز اما البنك
المركزي فيقتصر دوره على عمليات الشراء
لبناء الاحتياطات فقط فيما يقوم الجيش
وقوات الدعم بتامين الحمايه لهذه الشركات
ولشركات اخرى تعمل بشكل غير رسمي على
الاراضي السودانيه كالرمح النووي العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات